hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
here we are at the ask me anything
episode for May 20 27 for month I
suppose of our lockdown quarantine
pandemic situation I hope everyone is
doing okay out there staying safe social
distancing and so forth you know what
I've been doing more or less I've been
doing the podcast as always doing also
my videos for the biggest ideas in the
universe and actually just because I'm
home all the time since I don't sort of
waste various bits of time either going
into the office or traveling which is a
much bigger waste of time for me and
it's not a waste of time travelling is
not a waste of time but it does take
time and it takes away from the
productivity level for other kinds of
things
I've been surprisingly productive on the
science front last year 2019 was a very
unproductive year for me in terms of
getting published papers but this year
looks to be much better I have two
papers very very close to being finished
I'm hoping to submit them here in May
and then two more papers that are pretty
far along that I'm optimistically in a
month or two should happen also so
that's a good year right there you know
four papers per year is probably about
my average over my career I really don't
know and never really calculated that
but uh but it seems like you know a
healthy amount and hopefully I'll be
able to get more which will make up for
the disaster that was last year the
videos are going well you know it took
as usual more time than I thought to
figure out how to do something new
you'll see that the video quality is is
much better on the more recent videos
than it was in the beginning ones you
know learning that's what it's all about
and I am no exception to that so I hope
that all that has been interesting and
useful for people the podcasts are going
great but of course they're all being
done remotely now which does raise an
interesting question about what is the
best way to do these podcasts you know I
definitely prefer doing them in person
and when I'm in person I can bring my
good microphones along you know the real
the real worry when you're talking to
someone who is remote is that you don't
control their audio quality right
I've gone to the point now where you can
use this program called Zen caster which
which records each person locally rather
than recording what you get over the
internet so the quality of your internet
connection doesn't really matter but the
quality of their microphone and their
audio space etc
matters a lot so when I record in person
even though I can bring my own
microphones and everything there's you
know maybe there's not a lot of good
places to put a microphone so that
people can be close to it when they talk
or maybe the room is very echoey or
maybe they're just not used to being
very close to a microphone and they sort
of move around a lot and so I've
actually had more success lately this
could change but more success lately at
getting the best audio quality out of
remote interviewing I don't let my
guests not have a good microphone
because I will send them a microphone
that's what is necessary but I can't
control of course the audio quality of
their room or you know how close they
are to the microphone or anything like
that and also Zen caster even though
it's very good is not perfect and
sometimes it's hard to hear what the
person says when you're talking to them
even though the recording goes fine etc
etc so anyway it's interesting because
you get a wider variety possible people
to talk to when you don't need to be in
their same physical location but people
for some reason not maybe not that
surprising people are more willing to
say yes if you if you say I will show up
at your office right then if you just
say I will mail you a microphone and
tell you when to talk to me or the
computer and of course it's a more
organic conversation better give and
take if you're there in the same room
with the person so anyway pluses and
minuses I think that overall it's going
pretty well and gonna continue so a big
reason why it's continuing is all you
wonderful folks out there in patreon
land so thanks so much for contributing
to keeping the mind can skate podcast
going and with that let's go
[Music]
first question this month is from Chris
who says how many hours of sleep do you
manage every day
that's a good question probably like
about seven hours I would say is an
average um you know I don't I'm not one
of these don't sleep very much people I
need my sleep if I'm if things are going
well it'll be eight hours honestly and
on some days of the week depending on
how things are going I will take the
twenty minute power nap in the middle of
the day to keep things going but yeah
about about seven hours actually like
despite the pandemic in quarantine etc
I've been sleeping fine only one night
recently did I have trouble sleeping a
lot of people are reporting that their
dreams are more vivid than usual and I
have been experiencing that apparently
it's some combination of you know
anxiety about the state of the world but
also just seeing the same environment
around day after day hour after hour not
giving a lot of different stimulation to
your brain contributes to this vividness
of your dreaming so I definitely am
experiencing that fall Heka valkia sorry
says if the strong nuclear force is
strong enough to hold together nuclei as
heavy as uranium despite electromagnetic
repulsion between protons why aren't
there much heavier isotopes of light
alum of light atoms say carbon 50 with a
nucleus composed only of neutrons be
stable so yeah this is a very good
question you know you you have this idea
in mind that on the one hand protons
which are positively charged push each
other away because of the
electromagnetic force but nucleons which
include both protons and neutrons pull
each other together on very short
distances so there's a competition so
some nuclei are stable and some are not
but it's very natural to ask well why
not just add more and more neutrons so
you're increasing the strong nuclear
force but you are decreasing the
electromagnetic repulsion and the answer
is because the neutron is not stable the
neutrons a little bit heavier than the
proton and a neutron all by itself is
not stable at all it decays in a matter
of minutes into a proton and electron
and antineutrino
so it turns out just for a complicated
you have to go through the calculation
kind of reasons that the same thing is
true for just a bag of neutrons if you
try to make a nucleus
many many neutrons that does not make
them stable at all so the more neutrons
you put in the more likely it is those
neutrons will just decay into protons
and if those protons will be positively
charged and pushing apart all the other
protons that's why you get this balance
that gives us this interesting structure
in the periodic table
as for Parsi Box says what does a guy
like you make per year like what is my
own is my yearly income so as Ezra
surmises maybe I'm not gonna answer that
question you know that is a personal
question but I get the point of it I'm
you know as things go I'm pretty
successful I make I do fine let's put it
that way the joke that Jennifer and I
have is the the one thing that we lack
financially is the ability to take you
know business class flights on very very
long travels trips because for tall
people these economy class flights these
days man if you're on a 10-hour flight
it's tough but can't quite afford the
business class got to go in a car go
with everybody else but you know I have
I probably make less than the average
tenured professor because I'm a research
professor which is less prestigious but
then I also have the talking in the
podcasts and writing books especially
does bring an extra income so I'm doing
fine thanks for asking Johnny says what
do you make of ideas like the Dyson
Sphere and other giant structures like
that do you think realistically will
ever be possible to build anything even
remotely similar in scale I think so I
mean I don't see why not
in principle you know there's always the
question of the difference between
violating the laws of physics versus
doing crazily ambitious engineering
projects right so warp drive going
faster than the speed of light things
like that violate the laws of physics as
we currently understand them but taking
apart a planet and building a giant
sphere it might be plausible I really
don't know there's certainly nothing in
the laws of physics that would prevent
it I think honestly the biggest
difficulty would be disassembling a
planet to get enough stuff to build a
Dyson Sphere maybe either blow it up but
then you run the danger of losing a lot
of it probably the more sensible way is
to send rockets down and then throw
things up
you know if it's a if it's a rocky
planet you can sort of land on it and
you know throw rocks into space Robert
Heinlein talked about this in the moon
is a harsh mistress and then someone in
space could collect those rocks and use
them to build something like that but
honestly I have zero actual technical
knowledge of this so you shouldn't
believe my judgement very much but I so
my judgement is Mitch Lindgren says I'm
hoping you can comment on Eric
Weinstein's theory of geometric unity
what it actually means in terms of
layperson can understand so I cannot
comment because I have no idea what is
in Eric's theory it's not really
something that I've been following are
very interested in judith marsh says in
john wheelers book journey into gravity
and space-time he says that if we were
floating in space between galaxies we
wouldn't see any light from other stars
or galaxies is the space between
galaxies so vast it'll be completely
dark to our unaided eyes I have no idea
what's going on sorry Judith in this
particular quote in if you were in the
space between galaxies of course you
would see other galaxies
you know galaxies are faint to be fair
the Andromeda galaxy is about as dim as
the dimmest star that we can see with
the naked eye if you were in a pretty
picked a spot carefully in the universe
then all of the galaxies that there be
no galaxies close enough to you to be
visible if you were if you sort of if
the earth were where you were right so
if you were looking through the Earth's
atmosphere of course if you're truly in
outer space you're not looking through
the Earth's atmosphere so things look a
little bit brighter so in that sense you
probably still I think would be able to
see galaxies but you know the Andromeda
galaxy is pretty close to us so I guess
as I'm saying this out loud I'm getting
in mind what Wheeler probably had in
mind the Andromeda galaxy is big and
it's relatively close to us and yet it
is approximately too bright the
brightness brightness of the dimmest
star visible with the naked eye so
there's two competing effects if you're
an intergalactic space you'd be farther
away from all the galaxies but you
wouldn't have the Earth's atmosphere in
the way so it's possible that he did the
calculation which I didn't do which says
that at the end of the day the human eye
would not be able to perceive any of the
galaxies
out there so that is that as possible of
course all you need is good set of
binoculars or a tiny telescope and you
would see all sorts of galaxies David
lang says physicists have used to finely
tuned optical lattice clocks one at the
base and one at the observatory floor
450 meters of Tokyo Skytree tower to
make new ultra precise measurements of
the time dilation effect predicted by
Einstein's theory of general relativity
time runs slightly more slowly at the
base of the tower than at the top it's
only 450 meters tall if it were
significantly taller the top clock would
dilate more because of the motion of the
earth so anyway and the question is is
there a name for this point the height
of the tower at which the dilation for
motion at the top level is equal to the
dilation from the gravity well on the
ground level so let me mention it
because I think I think it comes up
later in the AMA I am never gonna use
phrases like the clock runs slower deep
in a gravitational field or something
like that
clocks move at one second per second
what other speed could they possibly
move at there's a temptation to say that
they move slower because you're
imagining comparing them to clocks that
are far away but clocks that are far
away can't be directly compared with
clocks that are in a gravitational well
or moving at the speed of light that's
part of the point of general relativity
all you can compare is the net amount of
duration measured by two clocks that
start at the same point go off and
travel somewhere and then come back
but anyway having said all that I have
no idea what the difference what the
point at which the height of a tower and
therefore the change in the
gravitational potential wins or losses
versus the speed at which things travel
so the point here is that of course
compared if you if you could compare to
someone that was far away from the earth
and just sitting stationary with respect
to it and then you both send people off
really fast and sent them deep into the
Earth's gravitational field and compared
how long it took their clocks to go
different amounts when they came back
then there's competing effects because
you know there's the speed of light
effect when as you go through speed at
through space just a special
relativistic effect and then there's the
gravitational time dilation and so
David's question is when does the
velocity at which you're moving
more important than the gravitational
time dilation the answer is I have no
idea I mean you could do the calculation
but I have not done it sorry Kirk Briggs
says if the past and future are not as
Eddington said as much available to
present exploration as the distant parts
of space then I don't see how you can
justify that they are equally real you
consider yourself an eternal ist's but
if the past isn't always including now
out there on some space-time world point
then what is eternal about your view I
think I must not quite be understanding
the question because I think that
Eddington's quote answers the question I
mean Eddington is saying that the past
and future are as much available to
present exploration as the distant parts
of space so an eternal list says that
the past and future are equally real to
distant parts of space there's no
difference between being distant in
space and being distant in time
according to the block universe point of
view so the only thing that I've said
that before will say again is that
they're not real now you can't add these
temporal modifiers but that's ok the
whole point of the four-dimensional
perspective is that you shouldn't add
these temporal modifiers you should just
say they're real . greg Griffiths says
what do recent indications the different
generation process for type 1a
supernovae may have differed in
prevalence in the early universe and
more recently the potential and I saw
trippy in the expansion imply for the
Hubble constant measurement discrepancy
or the contribution of dark energy I'm
really not able to give a detailed
expert level answer on this because I
have not followed all the recent claims
and counterclaims about the Hubble
constant discrepancy the anisotropy etc
there was a claim for those of you who
don't know there was a claim recently
that the expansion of the universe was
anisotropic now almost no professional
cosmologists believes that claim because
the measurement is done using galaxies
and you can do that you can try to
measure the isotropy of the universe
using galaxies but it's nowhere near as
accurate or precise or as easy to
measure as doing it using the Cosmic
Microwave Background and we've done it
using the Cosmic Microwave Background
and it's isotropic so you're using a
worse method with larger error bars
and getting a claim that doesn't seem to
make sense probably the claims just not
right that's how Bayesian inference
works for the Hubble constant
discrepancy it's a it's a more
interesting discrepancy the people who
are doing it know what they're doing and
we don't know exactly what's going on my
bet is still that it's just gonna go
away when we understand the observations
better that it's not really new physics
that's my personal belief jessie Rimmer
says recently you tweeted out a blog
post by Stephen Wolfram where he writes
excitedly about a new way of conceiving
fundamental laws of physics I enjoyed
his post but I also took note of your
wise words of caution about getting too
excited my question is why would a
scientist of stature opted to post
something for public consumption without
submitting it to formal peer review
first so I think this is there's a
couple things going on here so plenty of
scientists including myself submit
things and make them publicly available
before they've been formally peer
reviewed that's the whole purpose of the
well that's a role that is played maybe
it's not the whole purpose by the
archive in high energy physics and it's
corresponding there's a bio archive and
a medical archive etc you can put out
preprints that is to say papers you've
written that have not yet been
peer-reviewed that usually will
eventually be peer-reviewed but you can
get sort of a pre peer review peer
review by just putting them out there in
public
letting your peers the rest of the
scientific community look at them and
comment and cite them and so forth and
if they're good you know use them even
before they've appeared in a journal so
the fact that it's not submitted in a
peer reviewed journal doesn't bother me
at all
if it eventually is submitted to a peer
review journal but I the reason why I'm
not that excited about it is you know
again people should go ahead and do it
like I'm not gonna say don't do your
crazy ideas about fundamental physics to
the people who are trying it knock
yourself out to go nuts to the people
who are just on the sidelines asking how
much should I care about this my answer
is you should not care about this kind
of thing very much for lots of reasons
you know the the there's not just one
but a million different things that go
into creating an ambitious new picture
of physics like this and the ordinary
thing to do is to say well I'm making
twenty dramatically
incredibly implausible claims let me
justify them one by one in a series of
papers that can people can think about
you know lone geniuses just don't work
as well as communities and so real
physicists put their stuff out there
into the community and they talk about
it and they get it better and they
reference each other and they cite each
other and they build upon what each
other have done so if you say you know I
have a discrete model that mimics
quantum mechanics and satisfies Bell's
Theorem and that's step three out of
twenty in making your theory of
everything well jeez that's a big enough
thing you should write a short paper
about that and let people talk about
that and that's the kind of thing that
makes me not that interested or not that
gives me a very small prior on an
approach like this being very useful is
that it's just it it smells wrong right
it like doesn't have any of the
qualities that they're trying in good
faith to address all of the big obstacle
obstacle to an approach like this I mean
maybe they will like I said you know
there's some nonzero chance and if they
do then people will talk about it and
people will realize it but I would have
much higher confidence if they just done
it piecemeal in a way that said you know
here's why we think we can do this
here's why we think we can do that
here's why we think we do something else
I mean the model is irreversible it
looks very non-local it's discrete it's
not Lorentz invariant it doesn't look
quantum mechanical at all so if someone
says but maybe it's right all you have
to do is spend the next three weeks of
your life reading through the 800 pages
they've written yeah no I'm not gonna do
that you know if you look on the
archives I just talked about in particle
physics and high-energy Theory there are
literally hundreds of papers coming out
every week by physicists who are in the
game who are playing by the rules who
are putting papers out letting other
people comment on them giving seminars
and so forth why would I spend time
listening to you know someone's
grandiose plans when I know these other
people are doing their best to write
papers in good faith and I don't even
have time to read their papers you know
I might have time to read one or two
papers out of a hundred that actually
get published there so Peter Golay says
consider a three-dimensional object
falling through the plane of
two dimensional worlds say a pencil
following point first to a
two-dimensional creature it would look
like a point appearing out of nowhere
then widening into a disc than
disappearing is this in any way
analogous to quantum particles
materializing and disappearing
suggesting a source in a higher physical
dimension so no it is in no way
analogous to that I see where you're
coming from but the idea of quantum
particles materializing and disappearing
was always a wrong analogy it was just a
sort of fake story that was told if you
want more lowdown on that I go into some
length about it in something deeply
hidden in my recent book there's an
appendix where I talk about Flyman
diagrams and quantum fluctuations and so
forth but the point is that in quantum
mechanics as we understand it we have
the Schrodinger equation okay and we
don't have to go into the details about
that but the point is the universe
evolves like a closed system it evolves
like you tell me what the quantum state
is the Schrodinger equation tells me how
it evolves whereas the process that
you're suggesting where something comes
in from an extra dimension and looks
mysterious to us looks like it's popping
into existence that's because the plane
into which the pencil is coming is not a
closed system it's being influenced by
the outside world in some way so as best
as we currently understand it the laws
of physics do not need any influence
coming out from outside so that's why I
don't think this is an especially good
analogy for quantum fluctuations Richard
monster says since forces allow one
object to influence another and since
entanglement allows one object to
influence another object is there a way
to express entanglement and forces in
terms of one another or are they two
completely different mechanisms by which
an object can influence another object
I think the dirty secret here is that
the word force is not actually
well-defined in physics or at least it's
not uniquely defined in a way we can all
agree on in Newtonian mechanics it was
but now we're talking about quantum
mechanics and things are a little bit
more subtle and furthermore we're
talking about field theory because
quantum field theory is our best theory
of the world where it's also more subtle
than that so I think that it makes
perfect sense not to mix together
entanglement and forces because the way
that we have actually gone about in
practice using the word for
is to refer to you know the famous four
forces of physics gravity
electromagnetism the strong weak nuclear
forces you can also add the Higgs force
onto that it's very very short-range but
in principle it's there and so in
practice what we mean is a boson ik
field okay that can either pull or push
other fields together and work working
completely locally entanglement to
something are really different than that
right entanglement is not mediated by a
field it does seem to be an influence
whether or not you want to call it a
force but people disagree depending on
whether there are many worlds ours or
Multan variable people or something else
about how entanglement and the
measurement process actually works but
in none of their views do you need a
force to make it happen so I was
probably not a good thing to mix those
two up
John Hamel says he discussed the idea
that free will skeptics are simply not
being consistent unless they act in a
really a social and sociopathic way so
parenthetically I've never said that you
say I discussed the idea well someone
else uses those words and I'll discuss
those words but those are not my words
just to be clear I'm a free will skeptic
John goes on to say I think that the wet
me computer my head attempts to
calculate the outcomes of various
decisions and that evolutionary
influences and other factors give me a
preference for outcomes that benefit me
and society is there any part of this
perspective that implies I should behave
like a sociopath in order to be
consistent so in this perspective where
I mean I I completely agree that you are
a wet meat computer that attempts to do
things in evolution etc gives you
preference for outcomes and I also think
that you should talk about your
decision-making process using freewill
choice based vocabulary the point at
which you become inconsistent is when
you say well I refuse to talk about
human choices and volition and freewill
but I still want to use words like
should and morally right and wrong and
responsibility and blame and things like
that I think that is inconsistent I
think you should choose either to use
words like responsibility blame morally
right and wrong along with
words like choices and volition or use
none of those words if you can't make
choices then there's no sense in which
your actions are right or wrong it just
doesn't quite make sense so an analogy
to me is imagine that Thanos from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe takes Captain
America at the top of a tall building
and throws Captain America off the
building and capped America does not
have the ability to fly for those of you
familiar with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and cap ends up landing on the
ground and landing right on an innocent
bystander who is thereby immediately
killed so would we say that Captain
America has made a morally wrong action
that Captain America is to blame for
what happened I think we would say no
because there's once we had the initial
conditions the Captain America has been
thrown out the window or thrown off the
roof of a tall building there's nothing
that that given that given that
information there's nothing that Captain
America can do to prevent him from
falling onto the ground and killing that
person who doesn't have the ability to
move out fast enough right the laws of
physics have declared that that's what's
going to happen but what if we say do we
assign moral blame to Santos's action in
throwing Captain America out the window
or off the roof
well yes and the reason why that's a
sensible thing to do is because given
what we know given the conditions that
we were actually aware of like there
Thanos is there Thanos is a thinking
being with the ability to reason and we
can talk to him and try to make him make
choices and so forth given all that
information he could have acted
differently right he has the ability you
have given what we know is perfectly
consistent to imagine different futures
now you can counterfactually say but if
we were Laplace's demon and knew all the
atoms that Thanos is made of and
everybody else we could have predicted
it fine but we're not and that's why
rather than talking the language of I
just saw the wave function of the
universe every day we talk a language of
people making choices and assigning
blame and responsibility to the outcomes
of those choices Shaun K Davis says I
can understand how the curvature of
space causes objects to follow a
curved path around the center-of-mass
such as the planets orbiting the Sun
what I'm having trouble understanding is
how the curvature of space imparts on
those objects and acceleration towards
the center of mass what am I missing I
think you're missing the fact that
matter no bill you're missing this or
not but the fact is that curvature is
gravity right I mean so there may be
what you're asking is why you know I
guess me I'm trying to read the question
trying to figure out what exactly you're
asking there is a question that can be
asked which is why do particles or
objects moving through curved space-time
look like they're being pulled by
gravity right so on the one hand there's
the question why do particles moving
through curved space-time follow what we
call geodesics shortest distance paths
through space-time and that's something
you can derive from the laws of physics
right you don't just need to posit it
you can just posit it all so in fact in
the philosophy of general relativity
community there are arguments over
whether or not geodesic motion is
postulated or derived but anyway that is
part of Einstein's general theory of
relativity the other part is so why is
that action why are particles moving
along to your desks similar to what you
and I think of as gravity in particular
why's there an acceleration toward the
center of mass well any center of mass
curves space-time around it in a
particular way and then you do the math
I mean I'm not quite sure what level you
need a answer to this question I can do
the math I've written a book you can
write and you're gonna read space-time
in geometry you take Einstein's equation
for the curvature of space-time in the
presence of some mass you solve it you
get something for a spherically
symmetric mass that looks like the Swart
shield solution and then you look at the
geodesics in the Swart shield solution
and they fall right or they get bent
they get deflected as they as they move
by a mass I'm not quite sure what other
level you're looking for an answer to
this question sorry about that
humberto nany says are the gravitational
waves carrying oscillations in several
directions transverse to their path of
propagation like the electromagnetic
fields that travel together in
electromagnetic waves yes and no so
there you there's polarization and then
there's electric versus magnetic fields
so in
electromagnetic wave what you have is
there's our vibrations in both the
electric field and the magnetic field
and those vibrations are vertical and
perpendicular to the line of motion okay
so if there's a motion of a beam of
light an electromagnetic wave and the
fluctuations in the electric field are
perpendicular to the momentum of that
line of photons or whatever it is and
the oscillations in the magnetic field
are perpendicular to those of the
electric field okay so since there's
only three dimensions of space and three
perpendicular lines the momentum the
electric field and the magnetic field
they better all be mutually
perpendicular to each other and there's
no degree of freedom other than you know
you pick one and then we know the others
actually pick two and then we know the
other three so if you tell me the
momentum you tell me the electric field
I know what the magnetic field is doing
so the polarization is just the
direction in which the electric field is
pointing vertical polarized means the
electric field is vibrating up and down
in some reference frame horizontally
polarized it's the oscillating left and
right and there's complex circular
polarization and things like that but
you only need that the fact that the
magnetic field is perpendicular to the
electric field is separate from the fact
that there are polarizations that are
either vertical or horizontal now for
the gravitational field we can but
sometimes don't but sometimes do think
about the electric and the magnetic part
of the gravitational field it is a
slightly confusing nomenclature because
there's nothing to do with
electromagnetism but in the
gravitational wave there is a part of it
that has the features that resemble the
electric field and there's a part of it
that had features that resemble the
magnetic field so again you can buy my
general relativity book and see the
different components of a gravitational
wave expressed in terms of an electric
like part in the magnetic like part just
like an electromagnetic wave and also
just like an electromagnetic wave that's
separate from the polarization question
since a gravitational wave has sort of a
plus or X shaped polarization it's still
two polarizations but they look
different than the electromagnetic
polarization so there's a close analogy
here but they're different things John
Reynolds says I understand that equals
mc-squared
it's mass to energy and that the speed
of light is a factor what I don't
understand is why C is squared as
opposed to I guess you know to the first
power to the third power or whatever you
know part of this this is again one of
those questions where the answer there's
a perfectly respectable sensible answer
which is that's just the way it is those
are the laws of physics okay
now you can you know when you ask these
why questions you can always say well
what what are you gonna grant me what
postulates do I get to start with to
derive this fact that you want so one
way of doing it very very simple-minded
but it works is just to use dimensional
analysis right if you if you think about
the units of these quantities energy
mass and velocity you know that the
kinetic energy is one-half MV squared so
you know that the units in which energy
is measured whatever they are joules or
herbs or what-have-you
are the dimensions the units of mass
times the dimension of velocity squared
because it's one-half MV squared and 1/2
doesn't have dimensions at all so if you
if someone told you they had a formula
energy equals mass times the speed of
light to some power and they said what
is the power going to be you would
instantly know it has to be squared just
to get the unit's right now you can also
derive a equals MC squared in special
relativity in ways where the C squared
comes from the form of the Lorentz
transformation but then of course you're
assuming special relativity to begin
with so it all depends on what you're
allowing yourself to assume Joseph
hungred II says my question has to do
with first principles
can you define the word perpendicular
without referring to 90-degree angles or
two similar concepts which seem to be
human invented is there an opera re
meaning a perpendicular which arises
wholly from the fundamental laws of
physics and which would apply for all
succeeding spatial dimensions yes there
absolutely is you don't nothing is human
invented here this is geometry and it
depends you know as as before it depends
on how precise you want to be and what
postulates you want to start with let's
imagine that we have a background
geometry which we agree is Euclidian
okay in other words Pythagoras's theorem
is true initially parallel lines remain
parallel that kind of thing Euclid's
laws but in any number of dimensions
will allow it to be any no
dimensions then if you take for example
a dot on a line or a dot on a plane I
can draw a circle around that dot if the
dot is on a plane then the circle is one
dimensional right this is a
one-dimensional line that goes in a
circle around the dot if the dot is on a
line a circle is zero dimensional a zero
dimensional circle is embedded in a one
dimensional line it's just the two
points is just a set of two points
equidistant from the initial point that
you drew okay so now if you go
perpendicular if you draw a line
starting with an initial point and go
perpendicularly it's just the set of
points that are equidistant from the
circle okay the set of points that have
the same distance from all the points on
the circle so if you have just one dot
on a line and then your quote-unquote
circle is two equi distant points around
it then if you said if you ask yourself
what is the set of all points that are
equally distant from those two points
that are equally distant from the
original point that you started with you
would end up drawing a line that bisects
and is perpendicular to the original
line likewise if you had a point on a
plane with little circle around it and
asked the question what is the set of
points which are equidistant from all
points on that circle you just drew you
would again draw a line that is
perpendicular to that plane so you're
not using any human invented notions at
all you have these notions like distance
and planes and points and lines but
that's part of the fundamental
vocabulary of geometry it's not a human
it's not it's not subjective let's put
it that way
lynnium is yaara says how close to
discovering Einstein's special
relativity were Lorentz and panca ray
how far beyond them did Einstein go how
is punk arrays relativity of
simultaneity different from Einsteins so
these are all great questions and I'm
not really an expert on the history
enough to give you a definitive answer
here a great book you can read is
Einsteins clocks and punk arrays maps by
Peter Galison where he talks about not
only these questions but also the fact
that both punk ray and Einstein were
very much influenced by their day jobs
Einstein looking at clocks in the Patent
Office and
great looking at maps in the Bureau of
longitude for the French government I
think very roughly the story that we
tell ourselves which might have some
truth to it is that the math was all
there before Einstein came along the
math of special relativity Lorentz
transformations like you say the
relativity of simultaneity people like
Lorentz and Fitzgerald and Pont gray had
all put that together but what they had
the way that they thought of it was
different that's really what Einstein
added what they thought was that there
really was a Newtonian absolute space in
absolute time but then there was a set
of ways that things transformed so that
everything you could never measure what
that absolute space and time were and
they called it the ether and they
imagine that you could sensibly talk
about your velocity with respect to the
ether but he just couldn't measure it
and Einstein was the one who came along
and said actually well if that's true I
can even just as good a theory without
the ether at all I can just abandon the
ether and what you need to make that
make sense is a different notion of what
length means and what duration means how
time and space are measured and it was
eventually minkovski who was able to say
you know yeah let's meld them together
into one four-dimensional space-time so
Dan O'Neill says you've said that when
you first encountered Bell's Theorem it
wasn't the kind of epic moment I don't
know if ever come across the word FFA
m'q before having an epiphany I like it
at the fanuc moment for you that it has
been for some other physicists would you
say more about this do you think Bell's
discovery has been oversold I'm not sure
if I can say more about it I can say the
same the things I always say about it
which is the importance of Bell's
Theorem to how one thinks about quantum
mechanics depends a lot on how one
thinks about quantum mechanics so if you
think that we don't know how quantum
mechanics really works if you think that
quantum mechanics remains mysterious
that we can eventually figure it out but
right now we're still striving toward
that we're trying to build the correct
theory of quantum mechanics then Bell's
Theorem is incredibly important Bell's
Theorem is an incredibly strong
constraint on the ways you might imagine
making physical theories that match the
predictions of quantum mechanics in
particular if you're gonna have hidden
variables in your theories and they
better be non-local one way or the other
now on the other hand if you think you
basically know what quantum mechanics is
like I do like it's the many-worlds
version like everybody in quantum
mechanics and you think that the
interesting work to be done in the
foundations of quantum mechanics is the
very difficult and very unfinished job
of mapping everybody in quantum
mechanics onto the world that we see
that's a hard thing to do which we
haven't completely finished yet
then Bell's Theorem is just not
important it just doesn't play a role
like Bell's Theorem is just true in
everybody in quantum mechanics because
that theorem and it's true and everybody
in quantum mechanics is consistent with
the data there are assumptions that Bell
goes into making his predictions and one
of the assumptions is that experimental
outcomes have unique experimental
experiments I should to say have unique
outcomes but in many worlds they don't
in many worlds experiments have
different outcomes in different worlds
so Bell's Theorem is still
mathematically true as a theorem it's
just not relevant for many worlds so I
think it depends on what your
perspective is there andrey Mirabelli
says if I have two disjoint intervals on
a world line how would I pick out a
clock that can reliably tell me if the
two intervals have the same duration or
tell me their duration ratios that is
how would I decide which we current
processes are periodic so I think this
is a good question I've addressed it
before I think it's it's sort of not one
that physicists generally think about in
part because we kind of build in the
answers to our theories it's just a fact
of relativity that there's a way of
measuring time that there are things
that there's something called the
space-time interval and there's a way of
physical there's a set of physical ways
of measuring that space-time interval
using clocks but if you want to ask the
deeper question why is there any such
way why why do we have the confidence
that we can measure time using physical
objects then what I like to say is that
it's the empirical fact that the world
is full of clocks that is to say it's
the the world is full of objects that do
things repetitively cyclically over and
over again in a way that when you
compare them to each other they take the
same amount of time so it takes the same
amount of time for the earth to revolve
around the Sun and rotate its around its
axis
comparing to each other every single
year different atomic transitions with
different frequencies can be compared to
each other
pendulums rocking back and forth can be
competitive compared to each other the
universe is just full of clocks and so
as far as we can tell that's enough to
actually say that yes these clocks taken
together their mutual consistency
guarantees that they are reliable clocks
and then we can use them to measure time
even along completely disjoint intervals
in other words let's say yet another way
let's imagine that Thanos comes back to
us again
and he snaps his fingers and instead of
killing half of the living beings in the
universe he slows down time by a factor
of two everywhere in every single
process ok literally everything slows
down by a factor of two well that's
exactly the same as doing nothing is
completely meaningless slowing down time
by a factor of two because everything
slows down and you would still have the
fact that clocks are completely
compatible with each other and they
would measure the same amount of time
along different clocks so that kind of
difference is just completely
meaningless in physics dugsi says can
you explain how dimensions in Hilbert
space relate to the wave function and
the measurement problem I think the
answer is no and I suspect but I might
be being unfair here so correct me sorry
about if I am being unfair here Doug but
I think you might be misinterpreting the
word dimensions remember dimensions to
scientists and mathematicians just mean
a direction if you have a vector space a
space of things you can add together and
scale by real real numbers the dimension
just the number of basis vectors okay
it's not a place you can go or anything
like that so the when you talk about the
wave function the wave function is a
vector in a big vector space that vector
space is called Hilbert space so there's
a very direct relationship between the
number of dimensions of Hilbert space
and the wave function namely that the
wave function is a vector in a in a
vector space of that many dimensions the
measurement problem I don't think it is
I mean it
the dimensionality of hilbert space has
nothing special to do with the
measurement problem except insofar as
it's part of quantum mechanics and
quantum mechanics has to do with the
measurement problem so I think I might
be misunderstanding your question but
that's the best I can do right now Niraj
doob doob a says I'm confused by the
different explanations given by
physicists regarding what space is made
of is it purely a mathematical geometric
construct and therefore has no physical
constituents or does it comprise of
something physical such so it can be
loopy frothy at the Planck scale I mean
the honest answer is we have no idea
what space is really made of or even if
there is an answer to that question
right because once you start talking
about loopiness frothiness plunk scale
you're talking about quantum gravity and
we don't know what the right theory of
quantum gravity is so you should be
confused because we don't know the
answer to that question classically in
general relativity space or space-time
more properly is just one of the
fundamental ingredients it's not made of
anything else it's one of the things
that you pause it to exist and you can
talk about its properties its geometry
how it changes with time things like
that but in classical physics space
isn't made of anything in quantum
mechanics we just don't know Riverside
says I hear your point that unlikely
branches of the many-worlds universe are
proportionally less frequent than the
likely ones still I do not see how this
justifies a conclusion that the many
worlds theory should not affect our
everyday moral choices failing to
conduct a regular technical check-up of
your car is a somewhat risky behavior in
the stochastic environment but is
inevitable manslaughter in the
many-worlds universe someone will die as
a result of this oversight in some
however small portion of a near infinite
pool of branching worlds so I think this
I think we we talk to similar questions
in the last AMA and it's a Pascal's
wager kind of argument in my mind you're
saying sure this little thing is very
very unlikely but its consequences are
enormous Liebig so shouldn't it really
override all of our other considerations
but the problem with these really
unlikely things that there's a lot of
really unlikely things so you say if I
don't get a regular technical checkup of
my car then there's an infinite number
of universes where I hit somebody and
kill them by accident but there's also
an infinite number of
universes where because I didn't get a
check up on my car the car breaks down
and I stopped the trip I was taking and
I don't kill somebody so I've saved an
infinite number of lives as well and the
point is that you got to take seriously
the fact that these things are unlikely
there's a way way bigger infinity where
nothing special happens because of that
technical checkup you did or did not
have and that is the gonna be the one
that dominates your consideration you
can't just say I have a big number times
a tiny number therefore the result is
big if the tiny number is tiny enough
the result is still tiny even if the big
number is big there you go all right
Zayn itch counsellor says I've listened
to your Higgs boson Higgs boson and
Beyond lectures and there's something
deeply hidden audiobook and I hear
renormalization come up as a pivotal
solution to some nasty problems
involving infinities I'm wondering where
do these infinities come from why are
they troublesome and how does your
normalization pacify them so the
infinities in quantum field theory come
about because we have a very specific
way of doing quantum field theory and
that's because quantum field theory is
hard ok this sounds vague that'll get
specific in a second when we do quantum
field theory we generally start
classically right we start with the
classical field and then we quantize it
and in we do more than that not only do
we start with the classical field to
quantize it we start with a free field
so we mean by that is you have you know
the electron field the quark fields the
electromagnetic field etc have all these
fields and they're all interacting with
each other in complicated ways that make
it almost impossible to say exactly
what's going on so the technique used by
physicists is to say ok first imagine
that all these fields exist but by hand
turn off all their interactions that's
what it means to be a free field they're
just freely evolving all by themselves
they don't bump into each other they
don't notice each other ok then you can
solve the equations exactly
everything's great that's easy of course
it's completely uninteresting you have
literally no interactions between
anything so then you start turning on
the interactions and you treat them as
small and you say
okay I now have I went from zero
interaction to just a little bit of
interaction between my fields what
happens and this first answer you get in
this approximation where the interaction
is weak is everything's great
you know the fields sort of you have a
wave packet of one field and a wave
packet of another field representing two
particles they can bump into each other
you can calculate the probability that
they go separate ways and so forth but
then even try to improve this
calculation by adding another level of
approximation and everything falls apart
that's where you get the infinities in
particular because when you allow
different wavelengths of intermediate
States between the initial fields that
you have bumping into each other there's
an infinite number of wavelengths that
you can include you could go from you
know whatever tiny number you start with
because the particles are small all the
way down to zero zero wavelength and as
you probably know in quantum mechanics
small wavelengths means high energies so
you're going from regular energies up to
infinitely big energies and so you get
infinitely big Corrections to your
problems
now renormalization is the technique
that was developed to get rid of these
infinities but it's critically important
to realize the infinities aren't there
in nature the infinities aren't part of
quantum field theory the infinities are
because we human beings are sloppy and
bad at solving the equations of quantum
field theory so we use this weird way of
putting everything together okay so the
infinities are basically a way the
renormalization is basically a way of
keeping the infinities that we started
with but subtracting off another
infinity that we put in to get rid of
this new infinity and it does sound like
you're cheating and you know Fineman and
and Schwinger and so forth who invented
these techniques expressed skepticism
about their own techniques through the
rest of their lives but these days it
doesn't bother us that much because we
realized that all these infinities came
not only from we human beings being
sloppy about solving our theories but
also from taking seriously infinitely
big energy wavelengths right very tiny
wavelengths corresponding to infinite
energy particles and that's just not
realistic yeah they probably aren't
there all these things that are giving
us the infant
so this is why Ken Wilson who passed
away a couple years ago is a hero to
modern physicists because he's the one
who really understood following work by
others but he's really the one who
understood how if you what you can do is
renormalize not by taking infinity minus
infinity but just by explicitly
admitting that your theory is only
supposed to be good up to a certain
wavelength and then you can use that
that wavelength that energy as a way
parametrizing everything that could be
going on that you don't know about at
higher energies and you can construct
what is called an effective field theory
so these days modern approaches to
renormalization admit that everything we
are talking about in the real world is
an effective field theory and it's only
good up to some energy scale and we show
that the physical predictions of the
theory don't depend on what that energy
scale is and that's the renormalization
group so roughly speaking the very short
answer to your question is
renormalization is a way of treating
what happens at really really short
wavelengths and high energies in terms
of its impact on what we see at low
energies and long wavelengths and
bundling it up into all a sort of way
that we can handle it very effectively
Paul Meigs says is there a short answer
to how does simply having the wave
function of the universe evolved
according to the Schrodinger equation
lead directly in an unambiguously to an
ever Eddy in many-worlds universe
I don't know how short you want but the
answer is through initial conditions and
decoherence initial conditions because
the arrow of time plays an important
role in Eveready in quantum mechanics
just as it does in statistical mechanics
in statistical mechanics we start out
with a low entropy universe and entropy
goes up in Everett in many worlds we
start with a world with a wave function
that has very few branches and the
number of branches increases and
furthermore we start in in the most
straightforward way of talking about it
we start with a division into
macroscopic systems like you and your
measuring apparatus and your cats and so
forth and then an environment with a
bazillion degrees of freedom that we
don't keep track of right the
environment has the photons and the air
molecules and all that stuff and
gradually over time the wave function of
this
becomes more and more entangle with the
wavefunction of the environment and that
leads to decoherence because the
environment states that are associated
with different system states become
perpendicular to each other and that
makes them essentially separate worlds
they evolve completely independently
from each other they do not influence
each other there's no more interference
experiments you could imagine doing
where one world would affect the other I
have no idea whether or not that those
small number of words I just said make
any sense if you want the longer version
I can recommend a really good book about
quantum mechanics where I go into it in
great detail
Daniel Fox says my son just recently
heard of Eric Weinstein's gravity
unification theory since the subject is
variants like we head again
can you please please just briefly
explain your opinion of it my opinion of
it is I have no idea what's in it and
I'm probably not gonna learn about it
like I said there's way more other
things that I need to understand first
DP amara Soria says when we are speaking
of cosmic occurrences eg specific
fundamental forces separating out some
tiny number of seconds after the Big
Bang
what big clock are we referring to given
the time intervals are not absolute so
there's sort of two aspects of this
question one is the one we already
talked about you know how do we know
there are clocks right and the answer
there is that we still know the
fundamental physical processes we know
them pretty well just a second or a tiny
fraction of a second after the Big Bang
so we know how long things took and we
can even check our work using things
like the light element abundances left
over from the Big Bang and we find that
we got pretty much the right answer so
we think we're on the right track the
other aspect is of course there are
different trajectories you can move on
and therefore different amounts of time
measured by a different clock right just
using the rules of relativity and that
answer is just a very boring one that
the matter in the universe gives us a
rest frame right gives us a frame with
respect to which we can say we are at
rest with respect to on average the
other stuff in the universe and you can
say well I could choose to move at some
high velocity with respect to that rest
frame knock yourself out but what we
mean when we say ten to the minus ten
seconds or
one minute or a hundred thousand years
after the Big Bang is as measured by a
clock that is at rest with respect to
the average motion of stuff in the
universe
Brendan Hall says do you have any
personal interest in your heritage some
seem to enjoy learning about their own
genealogy while others see their family
history as less meaningful or totally
irrelevant I don't really have that much
interest I don't know anything about it
you know our family when when I grew up
liked to pretend that they were of Irish
descent but in fact they were mostly
Americans generations back the closest
ancestors I have that were not born in
the United States were two of my
great-grandparents were born in England
okay so I think that I'm just some
conglomeration of European ancestry that
had been in the United States for a long
time there were Carole's who signed the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution of the u.s. and I have zero
idea about whether I'm actually related
to them or not Joshua Hiller up says
have you had to learn new to you areas
of mathematics since you stopped being a
student and if you have how do you
prefer going about learning those areas
yeah you know not as many like you do
gained some expertise when you're a
student that's sort of your job and it's
always possible I mean this is a hobby
horse of mine so I don't wanna go on too
long about it but it's always possible
to do the thing you do as a graduate
student the kind of physics you do for
the rest of your life or the kind of
science you do more generally there's
usually you know enough to be done that
you don't run out of questions to ask
etc but I just can't it's just not my
style you know I like doing doing
different kinds of things so you know
very recently I've been learning a lot
about information theory and discrete
systems and things like queueing theory
there's you know probability and
statistics kinds of questions which
never had come up for me earlier in my
career and how do I learn about them you
know that I mean honestly you should buy
it good textbook and read it do some of
the problems in the textbook you can
there's good online courses these days
and of course there's sometimes good
review articles and things like that so
I don't have any special secrets for
learning those things you just gotta put
some time aside and bear down and do it
yeah
Brett Meeker says I noticed you tend to
avoid the problem of branching by
assuming there are almost an almost
infinite number of indistinguishable
worlds prior to a measurement so the
measurement is really a splitting of
worlds this is much more plausible than
saying a 50/50 measurement creates two
branches but a 50-point 1/40 9.9 creates
a thousand but it seems that the born
rule is still just an axiom and there is
no mechanism within the shortener
equation to produce this splitting so
there's no description of exactly when
the split develops so I'm not so again
I'm just this is a hard question for me
to answer because I don't know what your
background knowledge is I mean I've
written about exactly these questions at
great length I wrote a paper with chip
cbins
on deriving the born rule within the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics David Wallace and David
Deutsch have a different approach that
is very very popular and they've derived
the born rule within many worlds these
are all different approaches but they
get the same answer in my book something
deeply hidden I try it a sort of a
popular level to explain in great detail
why this is true so I'm not sure whether
like you're familiar with all that stuff
but sceptical about it in which case I
would need to know more specifically
what your skepticism comes from or
you're not familiar with it and what you
need is for me to say yes these are
these have all been answered these
questions now it's perfectly okay to not
believe the answer it's not everyone
believes what we say that's how you know
that's just how academia works but you
it is kind of meaningless just to say it
seems the born rule still an axiom the
born rule is absolutely not an axiom
within many worlds I mean it literally
is just not an axiom you can say it
cannot even be derived or you can say
yes it can be derived and we've derived
it but it's not an axiom nobody thinks
that it's an axiom P walder says Stephen
Wolfram's new theory shows that the
graph separating seems to imply the
existence of two separate universes with
the disconnected pieces of the graph
appear as black holes due to the event
horizon I have no idea
I have not followed that I do not know
how he gets relativity or reversible
laws of physics out of graphs so I'm not
the one to ask sorry Justin Bailey says
gravity is typically illustrated by for
example putting a bowling ball on a flat
sheet
and talking about how the sheet is
depressed but space is three-dimensional
so is there a better visualization for
gravity than the classic bowling ball on
a rubber sheet well I mean you can try
right but the problem is that we're bad
at visualizing things that are even
three-dimensional right because you have
to imagine sort of seeing into them they
have to be transparent or translucent or
something like that it happens all the
time in physics that we visualize
complicated things by simplifying down
to one or two dimensions even Hilbert
space which plausibly has at least a
dimensionality of 10 to the power 10 to
the power 122 is often approximated by
being two-dimensional we work with
qubits right that are two-dimensional so
I I suppose I could try to come up with
a better visualization but honestly my
real answer is two-dimensional
visualizations are fine that's there's
nothing wrong with that
we are constantly simplifying things and
there's a famous xkcd cartoon where you
know he gets at that he you know there's
a teacher writing on the blackboard the
rubber sheet analogy and someone raises
their hand and says it's like I don't
like the rubber sheet analogy because
it's gravity that is pulling down the
ball on the rubber sheet but you're
supposed to be explaining gravity so the
teacher just like looks at them in
exasperation says okay we'll do it the
right way
space-time is a lorenzi and four
dimensional manifold with a minus plus
plus plus signature obeying einstein's
equations drive with rehman curvature
tensor I mean there's a right way of
doing it right all of the visualizations
are just you know clutch II kinds of
helps that if you don't want to learn
the math and so you have to accept that
they will be imperfect in some way or
another
Stephon Bernie grrrrrr says why are you
so skeptical about Wolfram's initiative
is it the process he's chosen or is
there something fundamentally flawed
with the idea so I think I already
answered this one again more power to
him go try to do all the physics you
want to do I've explained why there was
a way that he could have proposed
presented his ideas that would have been
enormous Lee more persuasive facing up
to all the problems and ideas like this
have and knocking them down one by one
but given that I think that these
problems are big problems I think that
you know the they're not nothing that he
does is call
from the start he claims that maybe
quantum mechanics will come out of it
maybe Lorentz invariance will come out
of it maybe you know fine
but time is short got it pick different
things to live your life about just
because someone is making grandiose
claims doesn't mean I should drop what
I'm doing which i think is really fun
and interesting and think about what
they're doing instead so I'm not gonna
do that unless they give me a good
reason to do so in fact you know let's
let's put it this way the grandiosity of
the claim does not increase my interest
in trying to understand it the
grandiosity of the claim increases my
skepticism that they've gotten
everything right you know I think that
you know you should be especially
skeptical of incredibly grandiose claims
that come out of left field like that
you should not be especially excited
about them I did a I put up a tweet
about this let me go find it it's worth
doing I can do this in real time I think
and I you know secretly making making
fun of theirs there's just been a lot of
emails I've been getting from different
people who have theories of everything
you know it seems like quarantine is
really just generating a whole lot of
outsider physics
let's put it that way so I said where is
it where did it go I lost it sorry about
that yeah crackpot physics emails always
want to propose a theory of everything
why don't they ever think about the next
next to leading order and Jed eNOS soft
function for tw production I linked to a
paper which is actually like a real
physics paper by real physicists and the
title is next to next a leading order
and Jed eNOS soft function for tw
production the point is this is what
Thomas Kuhn calls normal science right
like the hard work of making little tiny
bits of progress and I am 99.9% sure
that that paper on the next NX leading
order approximation which I have not
read is completely believable right I
mean why in the world would they do that
when they put all that work into did not
get it right whereas someone just comes
along and says hey I have a new theory
of everything that is completely unlike
everything and you might be skeptical
but I haven't really explained why the
skepticism is unwarranted then I'm gonna
spend my time doing other thing sorry
and I try on the podcast to not hype up
this kind of thing so I get a million
different requests you know interviewed
this guy this guy's making
wild claims you know this person thinks
that UFOs cause quantum wavefunction
collapse I don't want to draw attention
that there's enough attention already
I'm trying my best to draw attention to
ideas I think are interesting whether or
not I agree with them or not
Rudie em says do you think that some of
the answers concerning the nature of
consciousness can be partially answered
within the realm of quantum mechanics
and physics referencing ideas like
Penrose and others so no I don't think
so I talked a little bit about this in
something deeply hidden and a little bit
about this also in the big picture I'm a
physicalist
I think the consciousness is just an
emergent phenomenon from the laws of
physics there is a good physics question
which people like Matthew Fisher at UC
Santa Barbara have tackled namely is a
classical model of the brain sufficient
to capture its actual physical behavior
or do we need to take into account
quantum entanglement and things like
that I mean after all the brain is made
of atoms made of particles made of
things that obey the rules of quantum
mechanics quantum entangled it might be
important but also the brain is a is a
wet noisy system which is exactly where
we should expect everything to decohere
very quickly in the classical
approximation to be very good so I don't
think that consciousness in particular
has anything to do with quantum
mechanics at all Simon Carter says I'm
really enjoying your biggest ideas in
the universe series what study do you do
before each episode or is it the case
that you know all the different subjects
off the top of your head so for the
biggest ideas series you know there's
there's a matter of how you spend your
time right and certainly there's a case
to be made that if I want to improve my
track record at getting scientific
papers published I shouldn't be making
videos at all but given that I'm making
the videos and given that in trying to
keep it reasonable once per week twice
per week cuz there's a Q&A the deal also
I gotta minimize something what I'm
minimizing is the preparation so
basically I spend a few minutes writing
a simple outline but I don't do research
I don't I don't want to talk about
things that I don't already know so the
short answer is the things I talk about
in that series are things I already know
but there's nothing special about me
they're almost everything that I say are
things that most people who have a PhD
in theoretical
physics would also know equally well I
have my own special take on them because
I have angles on different ideas but
it's not like my knowledge is way bigger
than other people's on these issues
Ricardo Rose era says could you explain
an experiment that would test many
worlds versus Copenhagen in quantum
mechanics so I can't because Copenhagen
is not well-defined
I have no idea what is meant by the
Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics the problem with Copenhagen is
you say you know I measure an object in
its wavefunction collapses but you never
say what do you mean by measuring you
never say you know what it means how
quickly it happens many worlds is
completely rigorously defined it says
that the Schrodinger equation is true at
every moment if you give me a version of
the Copenhagen interpretation that is
equally reason well defined that tells
me exactly when wave functions collapse
that would be something that we could
test because for one thing unless you
have hidden variables or something else
going on the energy of the wave function
changes when you do a experiment in
quantum in quantum measurement in the
Copenhagen interpretation so energy is
not conserved in the Copenhagen
interpretation in many worlds it's more
subtle because energy is overall
conserved in the glend wave function of
the universe but branch by branch might
not be so that kind of thing might very
well let you do an experiment but until
one of the two competitors is
well-defined
I cannot test them against each other
Benjamin Fedderson says here's thought
experiment an observer is inside a
satellite no windows in orbit around a
gravity well in the room is a computer
terminal connected to a main tower
outside of a room by a cable and let's
say it's running Minecraft when the
observer begins to play they notice that
the framerate is lagging would there be
any way for that observer to tell
whether lag is caused by the main power
being lowered into the gravity well and
being subjected to time dilation or
rather by another person in this room
next door trying to run another instance
of the program at the same time if not
with this represent another equivalence
principle similar to the equivalence
between gravity and acceleration so I
don't think so that yes so the idea if I
can shorten it down is I mean it can I
mean a locked spaceship but I have a
computer that is connected to the
outside world
the computer seems to be running slowly
can I tell the difference between it's
running slowly because of general
relativity versus it's running slowly
because someone is soaking up CPU cycles
on the server I don't think that you
necessarily could tell the difference
between that and but I don't think it's
another equivalence principle I think
it's the hoodlums principle you know I
think it this is saying that you know
it's it's a slightly B is slightly
roundabout argument but if the only
thing let me see let me see what the
best way to say this is you can use the
equivalence principle to derive the fact
that something that is far away
experiences time differently than
something that is at your point in the
gravitational potential well and from
that you could derive this result that's
all you need all you're using here is
the fact that there is gravitational
time dilation and the simple way of
saying your question is can you
distinguish gravitational time dilation
just from a system slowing down for some
other reason and the answer is no but I
think that's the ordinary equivalence
principle not a new one raus Hastings
says what are your favorite physics
books written by other authors is there
a particular book or books you consider
to be a must read I don't think is
anything it's a must read honestly even
my books or not must reads I mean you
should read them they make you better
people but you know there's a million
different people with different things
they might learn from different books so
I don't ever like to say the books are
must reads I do have a lot of books that
are that are special to me but you know
to be fair I don't read physics books by
other offered authors why would I do
that I did when I was younger when I was
not a physicist but now if I'm gonna
read a trade-level books for example I'm
gonna read about something's not physics
because I already know the physics stuff
right I want to learn about biology or
history or something like that I will
read textbooks like I said you know I'm
all these books on information theory
and probability that I'm supposed to be
reading but that's a little bit
different but still you know books come
out that I enjoy that I can tell her
very good you know it's got aaronsands
book on quantum computing since
Democritus is good Goethe Lesher Bach
was a classic that I read when I was a
kid
George gam mom's books like 1 2 3
infinity where other ones I read when I
was a kid
Janna Levin
cold how the universe got its spots I
really have enormous admiration for
because it's very different it uses
physics but it's also sort of a personal
quasi novelistic kind of story
Amanda Geffner wrote a wonderful book
about wheeler and Einstein and the
origin of the universe and things like
that so there's a bunch of books out
there that are that are really good in
different ways I'm trying to think like
all of the people who appeared on my
podcast have written good books
don't feel bad if I haven't mentioned
your name by explicitness alright
Santiago Torres says what are your
thoughts on the tension between
individual rights and economic growth
versus public health that we're seeing
play out throughout the country in
response to the coronavirus crisis it
seems that stay-at-home orders are
really the only effective tool we have
right now but an outspoken minority of
the public and politicians are growing
impatient you know I think that there is
there's a lot going on here one is that
there is of course in principle a
fascinating tug-of-war between different
kinds of social goals like health versus
wealth ok roughly speaking in practice I
don't think this is an example of this I
think that you know large number of
people dying would be really bad for the
economy so I think that both the health
and the wealth criteria both pointed to
saying keep the country shut down for a
while until we're sure that we have
dealt with the problem as well as we can
and then even when we reopen it be ready
to shut it down again if we see things
flare up once again obviously what we're
hoping for is a future regime where we
can test people enormous ly quickly in
enormous numbers so that we know when
things are safe even better be a vaccine
or something like that where people
could think that they personally are
very safe so right now I don't think
that realistically there's much actual
debate going on there there is that
other thing on the other side the way in
which we reopen is a very difficult
question right you know so you can say
all right the number of new cases per
day is seem to be going
down that's good we've been pretty good
about being responsible and so things
are getting better let's start coming
back to life a little bit you know let's
let hardware stores open or restaurants
you know but should you still have
concerts and things like that I think
that you can't predict ahead of time is
the most well-established fact you can't
predict ahead of time what will happen
when you do these things so when you do
them I think we should go slowly and
patiently I don't think that there are
that many people who are growing
impatient this is a very small number
that are noisy and I'm very happy to
ignore those people pari Romanowski says
when you're not an expert on a topic but
want to have an informed opinion what is
your strategy for developing that
opinion yeah that's a really important
question you know I think that I am a
believer in expertise and knowledge so I
look at people who are experts and do
have knowledge and but why that I mean
you know people who have a track record
who have established within that field
that they have a comp or something they
know about it that they've spoken about
it and maybe even contributed to it I
don't necessarily believe them just
because they are experts but if I have
two people with opinions one of them is
an expert and one is not I will put more
credence on the experts opinion than on
the non experts opinion there's a there
are higher-level considerations that
come into mind beyond whether a person
is an expert or not you can kind of try
to tell by how people talk about things
how trustworthy they are but by which I
mean you can be a super-duper expert in
something but you can also be a zealot
right you can be a fanatic you can be
dedicated to your particular take on
that thing and be really really really
good at it and yet not be trustworthy as
recline set on the podcast I did with
him you know nobody knows more about the
architecture of buildings and how they
can collapse then nine-one-one truthers
because this obsessed with this stuff
they're uh Turley unreliable about it
but they're incredibly knowledgeable
about it so you have to sort of convolve
your judgment of whether or not someone
is an expert with your judgment of their
judgment do they seem to be the kind of
person who says well
here's what I think but I'm not
completely sure here's the evidence I
had what I'm still learning versus the
kind of person who says I understand
this no one else understands this
everyone else is an idiot I have a new
way of doing things that is radically
different and only my genius is good
enough to comprehend it that kind of
person I don't put much is taken at all
Ian Robinson says guess what any further
thoughts on the Stephen Wolfram and
collaborators computational view of
reality
so I think I've said what I need to say
about Stephen Wolfram etc Manuel Pavan
says do you think anthropic reasoning is
a valuable intellectual tool yeah you
know in very very specific circumstances
so it's not I think there's there's sort
of a a very trivial obvious level at
which it's useful and there's a more
subtle level at which I'm not quite sure
I understand it I think I'm coming
closer the trivial level is this
there are selection effects in where
people and intelligent life forms appear
in the universe so if someone thought it
was a really good question to ask why in
the world did life arise on the surface
of the earth rather than the surface of
the Sun given that the Sun has a much
bigger surface you would expect it is
much more likely that life would arise
on the surface of the Sun well I think
that you there's a perfectly good
anthropic answer to that namely that the
surface of the Sun might be big but it's
not very hospitable of the existence of
life therefore I have answered that
question therefore that question is in
the pile of questions I'm not gonna
worry about anymore right so I think
that's a very trivial very true very
robust use of anthropic reasoning now
where it becomes much more problematic
and difficult and not necessarily wrong
but just you know legitimately difficult
or requiring care is where you want to
say what can I conclude about the wider
universe from my place in it so if there
is a universe where there's a set of
very different conditions like a
multiverse whether it's different
branches of the wavefunction or
different pocket universes in a
cosmology
how should I reason probabilistically
about what I expect to see in such a
universe
there is sort of the straightforward
idea that I should just imagine that
it's most likely that I am a typical
observer in that ensemble right and I
could even extend this to time as well
as space so I should be a typical
observer in the history of humanity
right if I'm given that I'm human
conditional eyes on the fact that I'm a
human being
we should be typical human beings that
that sort of has a sweetly reasonable
character to it right like of course
we're typical that seems very humble and
modest and that this leads to arguments
like that there's a famous thing called
the Doomsday argument which says that
humanity won't last too much longer I
mean too much might be you know a few
hundred thousand years but not millions
or billions of years why well because of
humanity lasts a million years and we
are not typical we are really right near
at the beginning but if you think we're
neither in the first five percent of all
human beings who ever lived
nor the last five percent then that
bounds where we are in the history of
humanity
I think that's complete nonsense to be
honest because there's no reason to
think that were typical observers within
humanity it sounds very humble but it's
anti humble because you're getting all
your leverage not from saying you are
typical but from saying typical people
are like you and that's not humble at
all I talked a little bit about this in
my paper on why Boltzmann brains are bad
it's called the presumptuous philosopher
problem and I'm actually you know I have
some notes for another paper that might
write someday about this about anthropic
reasoning more generally my favorite
paper ever written about anthropic
reasoning is by Redford Neill any al who
is a statistician of the University of
Toronto and it's called puzzles of
anthropic reasoning solved I forget that
exactly but solved or something like
that by fully non indexical conditioning
so he takes the opposite point of view
that rather than thinking that you're a
typical observer you should you should
take into account all of what you
already know about what kind of observer
you are and that's the only topic
reasoning you're allowed to do about
100% on board with this but I think it's
much better than the typical paper on
this stuff out there kam umbers says
could you recommend some classic papers
in your area of interest for the more
advanced but very much amateur physics
fan for context I'm Elaine's
gardener and carpenter but spend my
workdays listening to lectures and my
free time studying mathematics so you
know unfortunately this is I understand
why you're asking this question but I'm
not gonna be able to give you a very
satisfying answer can because we don't
read classic papers it's just not what
physicists do right when when a classic
paper is written typically it's at a
point in the history of the development
of physics where you're going out on
limb a little bit right you're literally
the first person Einstein inventing
general relativity like you know no one
before him really appreciated that
gravity was the curvature of space-time
and so he didn't have at his fingertips
the best most modern way of thinking
about it notation problems to solve that
you know the the paradigm that Thomas
Kuhn talked about in in the same book
structure of scientific revolutions and
so if you want to learn general
relativity honestly you could try
reading Einstein's original papers but
I've never read them you'd be much
better served reading my textbook
honestly or anyone else's textbook
because we're much better at explaining
general relativity now that Einstein was
we're much better at explaining quantum
mechanics than bore was etc or
Heisenberg or Schrodinger now there are
certain examples where it's fascinating
to read original papers it's fascinating
to read the EPR paper on quantum
correlations because they were trying to
make an argument that we still argue
about today it's fascinating to read
John bells original papers and some
things like that but to be honest I
don't have I mean it's fascinating to
read Stephen Weinberg's paper on the
electroweak theory that's simply called
a theory of leptons because it's kind of
you know it's one of those things where
the implications are so much bigger than
the rhetoric right he's like yeah here's
a theory of leptons maybe it works who
knows but it was you know enormous Lee
brilliant and influential in just a few
pages didn't take very long but for the
most part my point is that reading the
classic papers is not something we do
sorry Paul toric says in the Carrol Chen
2004 model of baby universes being born
with low entropy the baby spring from
random fluctuations in the vacuum of the
present universe of the parent universe
is there any way to avoid also getting
lots of Boltzmann brains from similar
fluctuations can we have this
explanation of our universes low entropy
and also be reasonably confident we
aren't both
brains so I think the answer is yes I
think this is exactly one of the
benefits of this model the point being
that counter-intuitively it is much
easier to fluctuate a whole new universe
than it is a brain and partly that's
because brains are big right you know
brains are a few pounds and a lot of
particles and very complex very specific
systems a universe you might think Wow
universe has even more particles and is
even more specific but that's not true
this is the beauty of general relativity
and inflationary cosmology you can make
a baby universe that is not much bigger
than the Planck scale and is completely
featureless has zero particles in it
just has energy and through the power of
inflation inflation can expand that
Planck scale thing to a macroscopic size
and through the power of quantum
mechanics and reheating it can turn that
energy into a large number of particles
so if you just do the math the number of
new universes you will make is much much
larger than the number of Boltzmann
brains you will make Marie Dunn says at
some point a podcast you mentioned
working on an iPad pro will you talk a
bit about what programs you use your
workflow how you organize etc yeah I
mean a little bit but you know I'm not
that systematic I'm not sort of a
workflow fetishist I take what is
available to me you know for most of my
life I just worked on eight and a half
and 11 by 11 pieces of paper with a pen
someone asked me previously my favorite
pens the uniball vision elite remains my
favorite pen and then I would just stick
my loose pieces of paper into manila
envelope files and filed them away these
days it's much more often done on the
iPad with the Apple pencil and I use
either note ability or note plus these
are two programs that make it very easy
to write equations and stuff like that
what makes them especially nice is that
they are you know they basically output
PDFs which you can then print and also
that you can import PDFs so like for
signing documents and for filling out
forms and stuff like that it's very
helpful you can import someone's paper
and you can read it and take notes on it
right you can have a red pen and circle
things you think are important in the
paper and so forth so
I'm not completely organized in my way
of doing that but that's mostly what I
do these days there was something else I
was gonna say about that
oh yeah recording equations there is
this amazing thing that you know I Tek
my papers lay tech my papers like
everybody else does and there's this
wonderful program you can get at least
for the Mac I think is available
everyone called what's it called darn it
math snip is that what it's called math
picks I forget I'm looking for I'm
actually using a program right now and
it's not telling me what the program is
so sorry about that preferences it's
just not giving me the name of the
program I think it's called math picks
anyway the point of it is sorry about
this the point of it is you can write
basically what it does is on your screen
of your laptop you can snap a screenshot
of a region of your screen that has
equations and this will turn them into
latex equation formulas right so if you
have someone else's paper you can
screenshot to their equation and turn
into latex and drop into your paper but
even better it has quite good
handwriting recognition abilities so I
can write equations in notes plus or
notability import them as PDFs to my
laptop and I just did this yesterday
there's a long series of four equations
with a lot of Greek symbols and so forth
just to snap them in here and get it
turned into latex without doing any
typing it's not perfect you know my
letter Gees and my number nines turned
out to be similar looking and things
like that but it's close enough that
it's way easier to do that go in and
edit than to type from scratch so that's
the only other clever trick that I use
okay so the file got too big from the
audio recording of this month's AMA for
patreon they won't let me upload a file
bigger than a certain size so this is
part one this is the end of part one
look for the other post where part two
of the IMA is going to be